well thousands of Syrian refugees are
expected to leave turkey a and head home
temporarily many are trying to find
missing family members Russell soda has
more from the border between turkey and
Syria
the Turkish Stadium borders border
crossing and not far away from here just
10 kilometers away it's the town of
jinderes inside Syria it is one of the
worst hit town in the Northwest as Syria
more than a thousand people have died in
the earthquake and so far in the
northwest of Syria there are 7 800
people that died and many of them are
still missing and they have the rubble
and 150 000 people are displaced here so
generous
salkin particularly these places were
the worst hit and now the eight Convoy
is quite late however through the last
couple of days they have they have
stopped up their affords to get the aid
to deliver the a to this much needed
places I have told to some of the
syrians they are quite sad and angry
they say we have been forgotten by the
International Community that they didn't
receive the proper equipment's proper
Aid food and they are suffering from the
lack of electricity lack of the Dead
heaters and and the water as well these
are the essentials in this much needed
places so I have talked to one of the
Syrian Rescuers here he said that
particularly during the first three days
they were just working with the
rudimentary equipments and they didn't
have any Digger or escalator or heavy
lifting machineries they were almost
working with their bare hands and they
said if they had modern equipments they
probably would be able able to save
thousands thousands of the the lives
here however that is the situation in in
Syria so these areas Northwest of Syria
have has been has been bombed heavily
bombed by the Syrian regime for over 12
years of the Civil War many of the
houses and the towns here are already
are already heavily shelled and damaged
or cracked and the people syrians have
built makeshift homes and the camps here
it wasn't too much but still it was home
for that however this earthquake has
taken that also from them so disaster
after disaster for syrians and while we
were the crossing the border here we
have seen hundreds of the Syrian
families that are trying to pass the
border to go inside Syria and to find
their relatives to or to to join their
funerals these syrians have made turkey
a home for themselves over the last
decade and now they have been hit by the
earth earthquake and inside Syria they
have thousands of the relatives they
have lost hundreds of their beloved ones
now they are trying to pass the border
and to join their funerals or to meet up
those who survived
all right let's get the latest situation
in antakia Natasha name is there Natasha
tell us what you've been seeing
I'm in a tent city in antakia we've been
following around two clinical
psychologists who are meeting with
earthquake survivors 13 and a half
million people across the South were
impacted by this earthquake they are
facing Myriad forms of trauma the trauma
of losing a loved one the trauma of
losing a home and that is why the
Turkish red crescent has deployed teams
across the South to offer much needed
Mental Health Services we're joined by
Aisha she's one of the clinical
psychologists we've been with today
thank you for joining us I know these
are such difficult days for you please
tell us what you've been hearing and
witnessing in the camp since you've
arrived uh
we have been here since the first day of
the earthquake like as TRC colleagues
were on the field like we are still on
the field working as a psychological
supporters
uh we are mostly doing psychological
first aid to the people who are facing
with this with this disaster with this
drama most of the people are having
um
most of the people are having
anxiety I mean their levels of anxiety
so high so we are first doing here like
observing people and then listening them
and then linking with them so this is
really important for them to be listened
to be understood by people so we are
taking responsibility here just to help
just to reduce their stress levels we
are afraid that after some time they
would face with PTSD post-traumatic
stress disorder
um these are the cases that we are
facing some of them are waiting the for
their relatives from the rebels so this
is really huge problem that we are
facing we're seeing so many children and
it's obviously heartwarming to me I was
having issues with the microphone it
dropped in a beautiful little girl right
before the wife came up and gave it to
me so there are moments of children
smiling and playing but obviously we're
also seeing a lot of children looking
shell-shocked what are you hearing from
children and what should we be
especially aware of when we talk about
the needs the mental health needs most
of the children are neglected here as we
observed because they're your parents
their relatives are you know facing with
this issue so they are also traumatized
emotionally unresponsiveness we are also
facing with these children they are in
shocked and some of them we are like
trying to play games you know the in
these ways this press they the express
their emotions and also some of the
children are repressing their emotions
so also this is not a normal situation
so we are trying to help them to be in a
normal way in a healthiest way to
express themselves here is clearly going
to be a kind of collective trauma here
in South Turkey what kind of behaviors
and how do you going forward do you
expect to see and how do you think it's
going to affect the fabric of society
for the future you mean
we would be facing with the PTSD
post-traumatic stress disorders after
six months maybe there are really lots
of things to do here like in a
psychological way is in a basic needs
because
for psychological first aid it also
means like giving someone blanket giving
someone a water for but for the future
to make them a shelters for them to be
you know to be resilient to be adapted
to the Future
thank you so much for the work that
you're doing and I know these are
difficult days they're not going to tell
you but these workers have also been
sleeping in cars and not showering and
will face a kind of trauma as well the
president of the Turkish red crescent
told me despite the services that they
are providing now that they are quote
humble compared to the enormous need
going forward
yes extraordinary worker Natasha thanks
very much indeed Natasha your name
reporting
now I said bake is also inside a
makeshift camp in arima
they have tents some of them have
heating many of them don't it is
bitterly cold here there's a constant
smell of burning in the air not only at
this camp but across the city of their
burning wood paper and plastic but there
is Aid getting in so if I can get Vulcan
to just show you uh people are lining up
to get their afternoon lunch now there
are meals provided several times a day
to people here there's water tanks that
come in there's trucks that take away
the rubbish but there there is a fear
that because of the lack of Sanitation
and people living so close together that
there will be a spread of disease but at
least there's one thing that there is
clothing there there is food getting in
but the other daily tasks are very
difficult like washing the children's
clothes washing dishes things like that
because of the cold temperatures are
extremely difficult for people they're
elsewhere in the city
and they are taking away uh the rubble
and we saw the municipality workers out
on the street uh cleaning up the those
streets but there is a real concern
about what happens next what happens
when all these people that you're seeing
uh here have stayed in the tents when do
they return to their homes what's
happened to their homes when they
demolish them when are they going to
start rebuilding president erdogan said
that they were rebuilt uh in a in a
year's time within a year but that's
still a huge task it's a vast area that
has been affected and for these people
they can't remain here for long it's
bitterly cold and they are struggling
even though ages get in so now the
question remains for the government and
the authorities how do they get people
out of these tent cities and back into
homes
all right let's now speak to Dr zahid
al-mansri he's the CEO of Physicians
across continents also head of Med
Global's admission to Turkey and Syria
and joins us now from gaziantep so
welcome to the program now you have been
in idlib and Aleppo in Syria for the
past five days or so I think just give
us an impression of what you've seen and
and what's required most
yes hello uh actually after all these 12
years of suffering in this area and we
have this earthquake now it's very
obvious that the people in this area are
in need of everything now the minimum
evaluation of the situation said that at
least 70 000 are in need of urgent
shelter doesn't mean that the others are
in a good situation it is a winter
weather and the temperature is below
zero at the evening it's very cold now
and people actually are suffering and
they are lacking all the needs for their
normal life of course in relation to the
health situation also large number of
trauma cases are now in the hospitals
and the humanitarian staff in different
ngos are working for the last almost
nine days with no stop
so in the first instance it was all
about dealing with trauma as you say and
that's still going on from the
earthquake itself from the actual event
of crushed Limbs and so forth now and
going forwards what will be the medical
priorities
yeah most of the trauma case is received
by the hospitals they are treated as a
life-saving intervention and now most of
them they will need a second
intervention for the definite treatment
like for example internal fixation on
the other hand hospitals already already
are suffering and we are concerned about
the safety and the health of the elderly
people of the children of their patients
with the chronic diseases for example
patient with adrenal chronic renal
failure chronic kidney failure they need
continuous dialysis sessions and these
centers are affected now and their
capacity decreasing while the number of
patients actually is increasing so we
think that the whole health system which
is already was fragile before the
earthquake is going to be in need of
support in all of the its levels not
only the trauma cases we are also
concerned about the issue of outbreaks
as you know that we have cholera before
that in this area in Syria in the last
year and the cholera outbreak was is
still there when the earthquake happened
so we are concerned about the safety of
water supply for these people and the
possibility of increasing number of
Cholera cases you summed it up didn't
you capacity decreasing the patient's
increasing and given the widespread
damage to say the least that we've seen
right across the board it's hard to
imagine how you're even beginning to be
able to treat
patients in the numbers that are
required
yeah we started to deal with the
life-saving intervention I mean patients
with the trauma and things like that you
know that Within These days most of the
chronic disease patients are not even
Consulting Health Facilities they are
just concentrating on their safety at
home or if they are actually outside in
one of the Timber collection centers so
most of these patients actually are in
need of support now and in the next
stage we are thinking about activating
large number of mobile clinics to visit
the patients at their camps and at their
Village and trying to to help them while
they are still there because we are
expecting that most of the patients will
not be able to access the fixed health
facilities in the next few weeks right I
mean of course this isn't just a
short-term problem not even a
medium-term problem it's going to
stretch long a long way into the future
certainly into the summer months the
displays will still be displaced then
what are your concerns about the ongoing
requirement for Medical Care yeah yeah
we are we are in the winter and we are
concerned about the diseases related to
the winter weather but now we are going
to the summer again and with all this
destruction and with all these
deficiency in the infrastructure we
should think about the next summer about
the possibility of outbreaks about the
uh
increased number of cases of Cholera and
we we should plan for that starting from
now also we should think about the
mental health of this community who are
affected by this catastrophic situation
we should provide them with psychosocial
support and of course we should
rehabilitate all the health facilities
and support them for the long-term use
we'll leave it there we wish you well
with all your efforts as I had al-masri
a CEO of Physicians across continents
thank you